it will come home to roost I mean here's
what's gonna happen is Facebook and
YouTube are gonna fall prey to their own
standards because if their standard is
that you're responsible for your
followers or I'm responsible for my
followers or Jordan or anybody else is
responsible for all the people who view
their stuff okay then why isn't Facebook
responsible for all the people posting
on its platform if they are right if
Facebook becomes responsible for all the
people posting on his platform they'll
be bankrupt in a week they've got a
problem
they really do because they have to
decide whether they are a platform or
whether they are a do-gooder publication
yeah I run I run a publication daily
wire it's openly conservative we make no
bones about that and we are responsible
for the content that appears on our
platform and if we say something to
family Tory we will be sued if we say
something that is false then we will be
sued presumably if you post something
false on Facebook Facebook doesn't get
sued but now Facebook has deemed itself
the morality police and they'll ban
people they don't like and moldicide
what editorially ought to be elevated
and what ought not to be elevated does
that sound more the phone company to you
or does that sound more like my website
where I decide what gets published and
what doesn't right because Facebook's
case for exemption from these laws is
well we're like the phone company right
when you're on the phone with somebody
if that person says something criminal
AT&T isn't responsible for the person
saying something criminal or terrible
it's just the phone company right
but Facebook isn't doing that Facebook
is jumping into the middle of
conversations and then saying well we
don't really like this conversation so
we're just gonna kind of shut it down
not because of legal threat but because
we just don't like it so are they
actually doing that are you to say if
you put a post up on Facebook and they
don't like the way you worded things or
described things where they actually
shut down your post what will they do so
they've done it in the past to some
conservative public on traversal because
they're not transparent at all right I
can tell you that the beginning of 2018
we lost about 35% of our traffic because
Facebook started cracking down on mostly
conservative sites they said that it was
kind of new sites generally but that's
not what the statistics showed they're
doing it more often with things that we
all sort of agree are bad right we all
agree white supremacy is bad white
nationalism is bad now they say they're
gonna censor that stuff but here's where
I'm uncomfortable I think that that
stuff is awful and evil and I those
people are the ones are they're the
reason I have personal security
but once you
get into the business of Facebook gets
to decide which speech is good and which
speech is bad there an editor yeah there
an editor even if I agree with their
assessment of what stuff is good and
what is bad I am not comfortable with
them in the driver's seat there and if
they are gonna be in the driver's seat
then they should be held liable for all
the stuff that's on their platform I
mean why is it the twit Twitter same
thing right why is it that Louis
Farrakhan is still on that platform but
Alex Jones is not like I don't like Alex
Jones his material or I've been very
very critical of Alex Jones I didn't
think he should get banned from from
Twitter unless he actually violated the
law unless he was responsible for a
violent threat unless he was defamatory
or something they're definitely going
down this road of being the moral
arbitrators they're they're the ones who
get to decide what the conversations are
and and that's an insane responsibility
the responsibility of getting to dictate
what should and should not be discussed
and to have it be a handful of people
and have these people almost almost
exclusively live in the Pacific that
whole tech community I mean it's all
tech liberals who really if you're
around those people they live in this
really strange
uber wealthy bubble of super genius
spectrum people who are coders and super
capitalists and people that are raising
money all over the place and designing
technology and they have an ideology and
it's not necessarily a bad one just just
being honest and upfront about what it
is it's it's incredibly progressive
which is very unusual for big business
right for big business to be just openly
transparently progressive and pushing
social justice it's very unusual well I
think that there is a sort of
misunderstanding of when we say what big
business is what big business is so I
think that there's a wide variety of
owners of businesses and how they think
about politics obviously you know Gates
is a progressive guy Warren Buffett's a
progressive guy they are now whole life
welcomes he's ruthless with Microsoft so
I think that there are a lot of people
listen I think that the vast majority
are bridges ruthless with Facebook and
he's progressive I think Jack Dorsey is
as ruthless as the next guy when it
comes to profit I mean he still got to
be answerable to the sheriff
I think I think a lot of the
progressivism is sort of a way to excuse
your own in your own involvement in the
capitalist market Facebook took off
don't be evil that was their thing don't
be evil they decide to remove that yes
Google right Google
yeah when Google did that I met Google
it's funny when you think something but
you're saying yeah when they did that
it's like why would you ever take off
don't be evil like that but here's my
thing here's my thing I think that if
our tech companies were honest they
should take that stuff off like stop
pretending you're do Gooding you're not
do Gooding you're providing a platform
and maybe the platform is the good right
in a capitalist economy the product that
you provide is the good I don't need
additional good to come from your
product right if you want to provide me
a solid morning drink right
I don't need your politics along with
that I just need the drink well if I
want a social media company I don't give
two craps about what Mark Zuckerberg
thinks about politics dude hasn't
studied it I don't care at all what Jack
Dorsey who vacations in Malaysia and
gets bitten by a million mosquitoes
while meditating it has to say about the
nature of life like why do I care about
Jack Dorsey's political view he has
provided me a good the good is this
basic chat room where I'm consuming news
how about that would just be enough but
it's not enough for a lot of these folks
it's it's the the kind of Huli from
Silicon Valley we're gonna pretend that
we're here to do good and it's not
enough just to acknowledge that may be
the thing that you provided is the good
like Bill Gates has done more good with
Microsoft and then he has done with any
of his charities he's even a lot of
money to charity but Microsoft has
provided legitimately hundreds of
thousands of jobs and created enormous
ly productive lines of business and made
enormous profit for a lot of people a
lot of people have stock in Microsoft as
they generate factual thing he has done
more good doing that than giving tens of
millions of dollars to to various
outside causes so it feels like a lot of
the progressivism in in corporate halls
and in Silicon Valley is bifurcated
mentally it's like people have it
they're like dolphins it's one side of
the brain on at a time here's my here's
my capitalists side where I go out and
make money and profit and then here's my
other side where I show people what a
great person I am by proclaiming that
I'm for Bernie Sanders while parking my
money offshore to make sure them they're
it's she
did from that from the taxman yeah well
that's a good assessment what I'm saying
is that the the don't be evil thing like
one of the things that I thought was a
what if that was like a legal decision
was me being cynical that they were
pulled into some sort of an office and
said if we say don't be evil and you
take someone off the platform you're
accusing them of evil I mean we should
slow that maybe I mean again this this
this self-assessment of you are the
moral police I find really troubling
it's so funny I'm the I'm the supposing
more or less right right I'm the
religious guy I'm the Orthodox Jew right
I talk about social standards and how
people should behave in their personal
life when it comes to government and
when it comes to me imposing my views on
you I am away less of a top-down tyrant
than any of the people in Silicon Valley
I am NOT here to tell you that you are
not allowed to be on a platform because
we disagree it's one thing if you're
threatening violence which is an actual
violation of law but this crap where
people like me because I believe in a
social fabric built on certain
judeo-christian values but I'm not
forcing you to be part of that and I'm
not I don't think the government should
compel you to be a part of that or I'm
the tyrant but the person who sits at
the top of Twitter or Facebook who is
saying that they get to police what you
see and they're going to nudge you in
the right direction nudge you in the
right direction without your consent
without them even telling them what
you're doing right they're just they're
gonna push you a little bit because they
know better than you and they can sort
of massage you and a better views if we
control your channels of information
this is something the Obama
administration was very fond of there's
a scholar named Cass Sunstein as a legal
scholar and he wrote a book called nut
she was very famous it was it was used
as sort of a handbook during the Obama
administration and the idea was well if
we can just use non-forcible means sort
of nudge people in a particular
direction without them even knowing
they're being nudged then shouldn't we
do that and I think no you shouldn't you
shouldn't because transparency is the
only way I can tell what kind of
bullshit you're trying to tell me well
not just that like you you're closing
down even conversation if as soon as
you're trying to silence this other
voice if you if you believe one thing
and another person believes a different
thing you should probably talk about it
and the way the way that I know for sure
there's something wrong with your
argument
is if what you're trying to do is you're
sneakily trying to silence these voices
and again as long as we're not talking
about threats of violence and as long as
we're not talking about harassment or
daxing right we're just talking about
conversation you're just talking about
people with differing points of view if
you want to silence differing points of
view I have to wonder about your intent
I have to wonder about whether you're
going into this conversation with good
faith I have to wonder whether you've
really objectively assessed whether or
not you your argument does hold up
against scrutiny because this is also
part of the problem and when you're in
an echo chamber you often don't
formulate these arguments very well like
when you confront people about certain
bias beliefs that they have and you you
have an opposing belief if they're part
of a bubble like sometimes they might
not have even ever considered some of
the things you have to say and I've seen
that with some of your videos yeah